BUZZER.
MAKE THE RIGHT READ, AND BE
AGGRESSIVE.
>> Mike: BULLOCK COMING IN TO
GUARD WESTBROOK.
FINNEY-SMITH GUARDING LeBRON
JAMES.
WESTBROOK IN TO JAMES.
SHOT CLOCK IS TURNED OFF.
>> Jeff: PORZINGIS, THE ONLY
SHOT BLOCKER, IS OUT OF THE
GAME.
>> Mike: JAMES DOUBLED.
FINDS ELLINGTON.
TO WESTBROOK.
FINAL SECONDS.
OUT TO REAVES, THREE-POINTER,
BANG!
REAVES GIVES THEM A THREE-POINT
LEAD WITH 0.9 REMAINING.
BULLOCK FROM HALF-COURT, OFF THE
MARK.
AND THE LAKERS SURVIVE IN
OVERTIME!
WHAT A FINISH HERE IN DALLAS.
>> Jeff: AND I THOUGHT HE GOT
FOULED, TOO.
>> Mike: AUSTIN REAVES, WHAT A
GAME.
5 OF 6 FROM THREE-POINT RANGE.
15 POINTS.
PLAYING ALL THE CRUNCH TIME
MINUTES.
AND THE LAKERS WIN THEIR THIRD
IN A ROW.
>> Mark: HOW ABOUT TRUSTING EACH
OTHER.
THE EXTRA PASS, TIME AND TIME
MADE AGAIN.
ELLINGTON TO WESTBROOK.
LeBRON TO ELLINGTON, ELLINGTON
TO WESTBROOK, AND WESTBROOK
FINDING REAVES.
>> Jeff: GOOD OFFENSE.
WESTBROOK TURNS IT DOWN.
FINDS REAVES.
THAT WAS RIGHT DOWN THE MIDDLE.
AND THEY HAD A FOUL TO GIVE.
>> Mike: THE 23-YEAR-OLD ROOKIE
OUT OF OKLAHOMA, WHO WASN'T
DRAFTED.
SIGNED AS A FREE AGENT WITH THE
LAKERS WITH THE BIGGEST MOMENT
OF